la reunión bilateral entre el presidente
del gobierno español Pedro Sánchez y el
presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro se
manifestó en la firma de varios acuerdos
de energía transporte conectividad y
digitalización educación o seguridad
sobre este tema España reforzó su apoyo
al plan de paz total de Petro y ha
anunciado un millón de euros en 2023
para ayudar al gobierno colombiano en el
proceso de diálogo con la guerrilla del
eln que Pedro Sánchez ha calificado de
Valiente y ambicioso en temas
comerciales Petro ha pedido que se
termine la relación de subordinación con
España y que el intercambio sea entre
iguales una relación que espera sea
también de sociedad durante la reunión
entre la Unión Europea y en julio para
conseguir un mundo más productivo y más
próspero y en el que latinoamérica deje
de ser el recinto de materias primas
para Europa también anunciaron la
renovación del acuerdo de migración
circular entre ambos países vigente
desde 2001 y la búsqueda de soluciones
para el drama migratorio en el Darién
Petro por su lado habló de la Reforma
laboral española a la que nombró como
ejemplo para Colombia afirmando que hay
que empezar a mirar el tiempo de vida
que deja el trabajo y no las horas en la
oficina sobre la emergencia climática
anunciaron una visión esperanzadora
compartida de transición ecológica y
transformación digital pero siempre
desde la cohesión social y territorial
el viaje de Gustavo Petro por Europa
finalizará con una visita de trabajo a
Portugal este fin de semana